c'est un mec qui va chez son médecin il
lui dit docteur j'ai un problème hier je
la semaine dernière je suis rentré chez
moi un peu plus tôt et j'ai vu ma femme
dans mon lit avec mon voisin je suis
parti dans la cuisine j'ai pris un
couteau je vais les tranché les deux je
vais me trancher la gorge et là docteur
un self-control docteur je pose le
couteau je ferme le tiroir je me fais un
petit café je réfléchis 5 minutes
lendemain rebelote je reviens un peu
plus tôt qui je vois dans mon lit ma
femme avec mon voisin et mon cousin
germain là je suis parti prendre le
pistolet je me dis je vais buter tout le
monde et m'envoyer une balle j'en ai
rien à [__] et là docteur un chef
contrôle docteur
allez je ferme le tiroir je me fais un
petit café je réfléchis 5 minutes le
lendemain rebelote je viens chez moi un
peu plus tôt qui je vois dans mon lit ma
femme le voisin et le concierge d'en bas
je vais dans le garage je me prends le
fusil je vais refuser tout le monde et
je vais m'envoyer une balle et là
docteur un chef contrôle donc je pose le
fusil sur le tiroir je me fais un petit
café je réfléchis 5 minutes et alors
dites-moi docteur c'est pas dangereux
pour ma santé tous ces petits cafés
[Applaudissements]